- [Instructor] In order
for emperor penguin chicks
to survive the harsh
weather in Antarctica,
its parents share the responsibilities
of incubating the eggs and traveling
to the ocean to gather food.
Alright, so let's look at the its
right over here, its parents.
So its
is this right over here,
its is a singular possessive pronoun.
Singular possessive pronoun
which is just a fancy way of saying
it's referring to one individual
thing possessing something.
Now here, are we referring
to one individual thing
possessing something?
Are we talking about one thing's parents?
Well let's look over here.
In order for emperor penguin chicks
emperor penguin chicks to survive
so we're talking about
many penguins' parents.
So it doesn't make sense to have
singular possessive pronoun.
The singular possessive
pronoun would make sense
if it said, in order for
an emperor penguin chick
to survive the harsh weather
in Antarctica, its parents.
So if they're just
talking about one chick,
but they're talking about many chicks
so we're going to need a plural.
We're going to need a plural possessive
possessive pronoun
and the one we would use is their.
So in order for emperor penguin chicks,
so we're talking about many things,
to survive the harsh
weather in Antarctica,
their parents share,
so this is going to be their
their parents share the
responsibilities of incubating
the eggs and traveling to
the ocean to gather food.
So that's this choice right over here.
So once again, we rule out this one
because that would be
if we're talking about
one penguin chick's parents.
So we're talking about many
penguin chicks' parents.
And so an it with an apostrophe S,
you might be tempted to think
that this is possessive
and this would still,
even if you're kind of confusing it
with its right over here,
this one actually here is a contraction.
So it apostrophe S is a contraction for
is a contraction for it is.
And the way that I remember
is its is like his or her.
Its, you wouldn't write his like that
you would write his or
you would write her.
And its is just if
you're not trying to talk
about the gender of whatever
is possessing things.
So her, his, its, in
any of these situations,
you wouldn't have an apostrophe.
It's with the apostrophe, that is it is.
Now we already talked about their
as being a plural possessive pronoun
and the right answer here.
And then you have there
which sounds exactly the same
but it is spelled T-H-E-R-E
and that one, you would say hey,
I didn't go there.
So it's a different
word, it sounds the same
but it's spelled differently
and it has a different meaning.
And this is actually
an embarrassing mistake
that I've made many times on emails
when I'm typing real fast
is where I'll type,
I'll use this for this,
I'll use this there for that their
or that their for this there.
So always double check
your emails for that,
I know it's a mistake that I've done
many times inadvertently.
Anyway, I hope you enjoyed that.